how do you feel like you make one video
every like month or two
and how do you like
well i mean you what that that's fair
right oh no that's okay okay that's more
than fair do you do you wish you could
make more yeah you you do oh for sure
because that's something that i feel
like we constantly struggle with too is
like
quantity quantity yeah and figuring it
but you like
i feel like there's times like with
music that we actually enjoy sitting on
something for a while working on it for
a long time yeah and then we release it
we're super proud of it yeah when you
release videos it's clear the quality is
there you work super hard on them like
you're the robot dog one i think is my
favorite youtube video of all time and
people feel the same way it's got like
what 700 000 likes or something like
that yeah it's almost 10 million views
now yeah yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
do you when you put something out like
that are you proud of like how long it
took you for sure i like i really like i
yeah i like the um like spending longer
on it than like spending shorter on it
it's just like more i think more fun for
me yeah it's it would be it would
probably it would suck the soul out of
my my entire body to like do it every
week or every two days or something yeah
that's just like that's just me though
your thought about like
a world where like what if you had a
team and you had like some crazy like
fantasy factory [ __ ] where you had to go
in and be like all right i want to do
this and then like they kind of do the
groundwork for you like do you think you
would put out more yeah like would you
want to be the knock boys of robotics
[Laughter]
i thought the dog to do a beer bong for
me yeah they probably which isn't that
far from what yeah
i thought about like getting more people
on board yeah it's like i do like a
horribly [ __ ] integrated process
though where it's like hard to get other
people to like help with stuff yeah um
because like even like the way i shoot
like make the video portion of it is
like is super brain damaged okay it's
horrid
like i don't shoot it all at once and
then edit i like shoot like 30 seconds
worth and go into premiere and drag it
in a premiere and then edit it to see
how it looks
i do i do that same [ __ ] dude it helps
me think of like this like what i need
to do next and like the story was yes
yes yes yeah because i can't like see
like figure it all out beforehand yeah
i'm bad at that
um so i can't get an editor when i'm
pulling that yeah yeah yeah
i feel like that's also how bo burnham
did his special did you watch his new
special oh i watched it last night yeah
same last night insane but it it doesn't
it is like that it's like it's so stream
of consciousness and you can tell he's
sitting down and writing it as he's
editing it for sure he's we're making it
yeah after that which i feel like you're
totally different i feel like your brain
is like you see the finished product
that's impressive and you're able to go
shoot something right and then relax
it's not a compliment
no but would you agree with that i mean
no yeah i think i can definitely piece
together um story lines like in my head
i i feel bad for noah whenever he's
cutting my videos because
i just i'm always just it's stream of
consciousness when i talk and then i
might go for like 20 minutes and then
i'll go up
that's not i'll be like the first five
minutes aren't gonna make sense because
i didn't piece together this thing so
i'm gonna say that whole thing over and
then i need to add this and then like
i'll do that so like i'll really [ __ ]
with him because i can imagine he's
already edited
i do that all the time yeah and then
he's like oh you [ __ ]
you know what no no not the last 30
minutes yeah
oh man yeah so what did you think of
this you liked it bo burnham's new
special oh it was like in
like very
insane it it made me feel bad though
yeah i'll probably never make something
as amazing and incredible as that
and
like holy [ __ ] like it was one of the
most impressive things i've ever seen
it's like my favorite surely my favorite
like netflix piece of content ever yeah
yeah it felt really really intimate like
it felt
like it was like a little bit inspiring
that way where it's like no it just
makes you want to go to a room and do
the same thing yes not that you not that
i could or anything obviously he's like
in a league of his own but like at least
try you know yeah it just like felt so
him
and like there was nobody else like it's
just his vision and like the most purest
form of that where it's like
start to finish it's all him and like
that i think is really inspiring [ __ ] it
so yeah you got to see it yeah no i mean
um it was pretty depressing i'm to watch
it
i'm going to watch it and come on with
just a just double down opinion against
everything you guys just said i think
it's just all right
i think it's just too easy i think he
lied actually i think he had a whole
team
different sets yeah
i think he had a whole team
[Laughter]
i think he did [ __ ] i don't know i think
he's [ __ ] i think he had a ghost
rider actually yeah that's a camera then
maybe i'm just like too dumb for to like
understand the whole thing but like my
favorite parts were like the
happy parts like the parts where he was
like
like making fun of [ __ ] like the white
woman instagram song and stuff like that
i was like i can [ __ ] and then some
songs i just didn't understand and i'm
like i think i'm just too dumb for this
they were also i mean i think they're
all sweet i like i i like the whole it
just felt like like i like this [ __ ]
where it's like i just can see that you
put all your time and effort into this
one thing yeah it's like i respect that
so much yeah yeah like holy [ __ ] how god
like a whole year your life spent on one
thing is really cool yeah i mean that's
what we were talking about before just
on steroids like he literally just
i mean you think about what it feels
like like i'm three weeks into a video
or something like that
like i worked on that darman one for a
long time right in like two weeks three
weeks in i'm like i don't know if
is this all for nothing like people are
gonna hate this yeah they're gonna
[ __ ] hate it imagine being a year
into it and you're like is this just
stupid yeah that's just straight anxiety
for the whole thing yeah yeah i mean not
that this even holds a candle to it but
finishing suki was like years of anxiety
yeah yeah see you've been there yeah
it's like it was the worst because
here's the thing that i really empathize
with like with filmmaking is
you probably sit on a film so long that
by the time you see the finished cut
you're like oh i should have just
rewrote like three quarters of this yeah
like you see all the [ __ ] you should
have did better yeah but like if you're
on some crazy budget like 10 30 50
million dollars you're like well it just
is that now and you have to [ __ ] pony
up for the one like the people who just
don't get that you dedicated your life
to and they're like
yeah i don't know wardrobe kind of stunk
man
the fight was kind of [ __ ] yeah yeah
i think um
isn't the way i saw there's something
about like the way marvel gets around
that is um they they make like the whole
movie in like 3d
renders and they'll do the whole movie
in like really shitty like 3d renders i
think i've heard this yeah it's [ __ ]
weird yeah but it's like it stops them
from like having that exact moment where
they're like i wish we did this bit
different yeah they can just see the
whole movie before it actually gets shot
oh wow so it's like a proof of concept
like it's a proof of concept entire
movie you should see them they're like
iron man's like [ __ ] doing this and
[ __ ]
but they get to see how it fits together
and they kind of get to avoid that that
the horrible feeling you get yeah i mean
have you have you ever noticed that like
no marvel movie up until like there was
a long period where they just were never
colored like did you ever notice that no
where there's very little it's just shot
raw what yeah because the studios don't
want to spend money on the color really
yeah i know that was the reason yeah
it's just
way too many scenes and like delivering
a film to a colorist is like oh is this
the chunk is this it is this the
rendering
um yes
from play let's see
let it maybe mute it so we don't yeah
damn those are pretty detailed though
yes it's pretty good this looks like a
children's video on youtube yeah one of
those like russian auto-generated
children's videos
it's like
elsa and woman or whatever the [ __ ] is
it
wait what [ __ ]
this is pretty real oh this is pretty
good they might have gone more intense
for like the really important scenes
yeah
no but i don't know these are the
animated ones
this is when the finished product is
actually a lot of the scenes go through
previz of different stages
um
oh that is that is
damn
shall they even shoot it yes
yeah you know it's getting a director
boner
i look like i was so funny i was um
alina and i were watching army of the
dead did you watch that i'm not uh zack
snyder thing on netflix um i'll save my
commentary but i was just laughing at us
because like we basically
we ruined some movies for ourselves
because her producer brain goes in oh
yeah and what i found is like we're just
talking over scenes being like yeah they
probably like they probably casted like
these people and this they probably did
this and she's like yeah to save money
yeah they probably and like we're just
and then i like had to snap out of him
like we didn't [ __ ] make the movie
just shut up oh yeah oh yeah that's a
problem with like learning [ __ ] yeah
you're like the problem with learning
[ __ ] it ruins everything all the
engagement yeah it's actually [ __ ] up
yeah yeah right like once you
like once you once i learned how to
write code i couldn't use an iphone app
without like thinking about how it was
built yeah do you get that like that
programmer rage when things are written
like ass really written like ass and
sometimes when like i see someone do
something like really hard but it's like
not done well i'm like it's okay you get
a pass yeah yeah i know how tough that
must have been yeah yeah i totally do
though yeah yeah when the [ __ ] i just
remember mr ux yeah oh man oh yeah
yeah when you know when a website is
cool but it's just bootstrap you're like
oh this is here we go i know how you did
that oh yeah you're like a little window
painting yeah yeah yeah
damn bro we're just like yeah this feels
good programmer
podcast
people are people listening right now is
like can you go back to talking about
balls and dicks and yeah maybe go back
to talking about boxing sounding go back
and talk about sound
[Laughter]
just in the chat
yo sounders make some noise in the chat
let us know if you're sounding along at
home sound off in the chat
sound off for the sounders
all three of us are chairs
[Laughter]
you